es la guardia nacional en el metro de
Ciudad de México
6060 efectivos de este cuerpo militar
fueron desplegados en el subterráneo en
los próximos meses harán presencia en
estaciones y otras instalaciones es la
reacción del gobierno de la capital
mexicana después de una serie de
accidentes en los últimos años son
acciones momentos
hechos atípicos que están ocurriendo en
el metro y nosotros lo que más nos
importa siempre es la ciudadanía son más
de cuatro millones de personas que están
utilizando el metro sin embargo algunos
viajeros no se sienten cómodos con la
presencia de militares en el metro
incluso Aunque estos vayan desarmados
un atentado como en Sinaloa o qué no los
policías hay bien su trabajo lo que
necesitamos nada más es mantenimiento el
metro funciona bien traslada mucha gente
Todos los días El sábado dos trenes
subterráneos chocaron entre estaciones
provocando una muerte y decenas de
heridos más grave fue en 2021 cuando un
puente del metro se derrumbo y murieron
26 personas además de cerca de 100
heridos tras ese accidente una
investigación culpó a las deficiencias
en la construcción por lo que 10 ex
funcionarios fueron acusados Aunque
ninguno encarcelado el precio del
tiquete del metro de Ciudad de México es
uno de los más baratos del mundo pero
los trabajadores denuncian un
presupuesto insuficiente mientras el
gobierno de López Obrador habla de
accidentes provocados